vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais l'un
des films les plus attendus de l'année
n'est ni un blockbuster de studio ni une
grosse comédie française
l'un des films les plus attendus de
l'année ses afters chapitre 2 la suite
des aventures amoureuses de tessa et
hardin un véritable petit phénomène dont
vous n'avez peut-être jamais entendu
parler pour en savoir plus notre
journaliste romain raynaldy est parti à
atlanta fin août 2019
ce jour là dans le hall d'un hôtel de la
ville ont tourné une des scènes les plus
importantes d'after we collide devenu en
français after chapitre 2 after l'une
des sagas littéraires romantique pour
ados les plus populaires au monde une
histoire née dans l'esprit d'anatot est
écrite sur son iphone en effet after est
à l'origine une fanfiction dédié au
chanteur harry styles publié sur un site
spécialisé
élu par plus d'un milliard de fans oui
j'ai bien dit un milliard
très vite c'est devenu une série de
livres à très gros succès et
l'adaptation du premier tome du livre au
cinéma a aussi rencontré un large public
pourquoi un tel succès pour cette
romance multimédia son auteur un à todd
a sa petite idée là-dessus
même message positif donc et triumph
immédiat en livres et en film le premier
after a bien marché en salle et
cartonner sur les smartphones des fans
du monde entier un public convaincu par
l'adaptation grâce au casting du couple
vedette joséphine langford la soeur de
catherine langford l'héroïne de la série
sortis in the reasons why joue là gentil
tessa amoureuse du bad boys à dean
interprété par irfan stéphane neveu de
ralph fiennes et voldemort enfants dans
de harry potter deux acteurs
parfaitement conscient de la grosse
attente des fans
à bariloche a expliqué qu' un homme
[Musique]
le deuxième épisode de la saga after en
plein tournage ce jour-là atlanta est
encore plus proche du livre que le
précédent selon anatolie qui nous
rappellent où nous en sommes
le film est réalisé par rogers kembo
l'auteur de sex intentions
ce qui explique sans doute le côté
humour tendance sexy de la scène qu'il
tournait ce jour là face à odos pour qui
le choix par dignité ça se
réconcilieront t-il réponse à la sortie
d'after chapitre 2 qui arrive très
bientôt en france
[Musique]